Reading changed dreams into life and life into dreams
and placed the universe of literature within reach of the boy I once was.
My mother told me the first things I wrote were continuations
of the stories I read
because it made me sad when they concluded
or because I wanted to change their endings.
And perhaps this is what I have spent my life doing
without realizing it:
prolonging in time, as I grew, matured, and aged, the stories
that filled my childhood with exaltation and adventures.
I wish my mother were here, a woman who was moved to tears
reading the poems of Amado Nervo and Pablo Neruda,
and Grandfather Pedro too, with his large nose
and gleaming bald head,
who celebrated my verses, and Uncle Lucho, who urged me
so energetically to throw myself body and soul
into writing even though literature, in that time and place,
compensated its devotees so badly.
Throughout my life I have had people like that at my side,
people who loved and encouraged me
and infected me with their faith when I had doubts.